just it has been an amazing season and
the tour continues to innovate uh in the
Chess World it is the moment we've all
been waiting for it is time to award our
winner and I'm gonna call upon Magnus
Carlson the world champion who has won
the meltwater Champions chest or 2022
Magnus congratulations
[Applause]
Magnus shot
the joy of winning the tour winning the
final event but also this incredible
form that you've been in just impressive
play throughout that's uh there have
been a lot of good events the Sierra not
tourism a little bit worse as well but
uh super happy to finish on on a high
note and uh today I was just uh it was
just a pleasure to to play knowing that
I had it in bag and I could uh just
relax
it's a pleasure for the Chess World to
watch you in this form as well now
Magnus you have decided to not defend
your world championship title winning
this tour this season does it have a
special meaning for you to assert your
domination yeah for sure I want to win
every tournament that I um that I play
and this is certainly no no exception
and
um yeah as I said it was very important
now to finish on on a high note
um I didn't win the last tournament that
I played also the first random World
Championship didn't
um go so well so yeah it was huge to set
the record straight here
and coming up for the next year there is
this huge news of a partnership between
play Magnus and chess.com with them
taking over Magnus what are your hopes
for the tour in the coming year
yeah I hope to continue to to play a lot
of events uh both in the tour and uh and
others uh so um uh nobody knows at this
point uh what's gonna what's gonna
happen but I think whatever whatever
will happen it will be good content
good content I have to ask you uh you
did start this whole whole tour during
the pandemic it was born out of the
pandemic back in 2020 how has it been
personally for you to see the tour grow
and expand and become what it is today
it's it's been um it's been great to um
to see and uh
um I hope that next season
um there will um also because there will
be no conflict of interest with uh just
the common most probably then there will
be uh
um an even steadier diet of the very uh
very top players uh participating in in
everyone everyone I think fans would
would love to to see that but um but
yeah the team does does a great job
um they're producing these events and I
especially love the the ones where you
play and uh where you play in the studio
and I was happy to finally do well in
one of those as well Champion Chester
was really he changed the way we play
chess it's transformed it into an esport
and you mentioned that you really enjoy
this format do you like it on site or do
you like it when you're playing a remote
no I I like I like both but it is it's
especially pleasurable to to play on on
site it's something uh it's something
else and it's uh it's a format that I
really think has potential for the
future also and you
yes you said there's so much to look
forward to this coming year but for now
how are you going to celebrate this big
win I haven't thought about
um celebration uh I'm for me the
celebration was explained today just uh
being here enjoying the fact that I had
um had a good season and I'd won this
tournament so that's all I need a
congratulations it is time now I wanted
to hand over the winners trophy to
Magnus please take over indeed and uh
last year the winner of the Metro
Championship tour got a nft only Trophy
this year we are stepping it up a little
bit so you get a physical trophy as well
that is yours and showing that is uh
Among Us Carson who's the winner of the
military Champions Chester 2022 and um
by that I hereby
declare you the winner of the meltwater
Japanese Chester 2022.
can you tell us a little bit about that
yes uh as I mentioned last year there
was nft trophy only so this year it's a
physical Trophy and an nft so there is
two versions of that nft one is yours to
keep and the other is now going up for
auction